hello and welcome to the immune oncology
session of advancing science
i'm peggy soderopoulou rnd director on
celiad
and i will accompany you in this track
clinical activity against cancer has
been a major shift in oncology over the
last few years
including areas of immunology that were
not anywhere near mainstream thinking
just a decade ago as illustrated in this
graph
published in nature reviews and drug
discovery leaning oncology therapeutic
agents
under clinical testing have almost
doubled between 2017 and 2019
a fact that is also reflected by 31 new
fda approvals
during the la this two-year period
immuno-oncology
is clearly in a time of strong
development initially
antibodies paved the way with paradigm
and changing treatments
while recently there is a big interest
in cell therapy
with the cd19 cartese certainly
impacting the global
hematology practice importantly with
increased understanding of molecular
immunology
the field is now expanding including
revisiting concepts that have failed in
the past
such as cytokines nk cells disease
as understanding the complexity of the
system allows stacking the reasons
for the original failure
summarizing the different areas being
include
being explored today we could group the
immunotherapy
in therapeutic modality oncology in six
groups
monoclonal antibodies that can target
only tumor antigens
or tumor antigens and a androgen immune
cells tethering them for cell killing
checkpoint inhibitors which will release
the breaks hindering host immune
responses
therapeutic vaccines that are targeting
in boosting the immune system
adaptive cell transfer autologous or
allergenic
this one ones will have the focus lately
in cardi cells in engineered tcrt cells
oncolytic viruses that can kill cancer
cells but at the same time
activate and the tumor immunity and the
recently immersed microbiome
which have been proposed as therapeutic
prognostic
or diagnostic tool of course there's
still a lot of
challenges that we have to tackle such
as enabling the increased efficacy
and reduced toxicity of the therapeutic
approaches and we can do this by
understanding the complex network
of immune pathways in the role of
district immune cells populations
to understand the patient responses
through basic and translational research
being able to predict the patient
responses by developing reliable
prognostic biomarkers
enable solid science by developing
improved models to better understand the
underlying mechanisms of the outcomes of
tumor immunotherapy
and implementing the new technology
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
to be able to integrate the real-world
data in the single cell oh mixed data
to recognize specific patterns of immune
responses
without further ado i would like to
introduce you to the agenda
of this meeting we have four speakers
peter nelson
sergio rotella juras adamic and jenny
croning
that will talk to us about the landscape
of the immune microenvironment in
metastatic prostate cancer
for the correlation of immune filtration
with 53 mutational status
in the multi-cohort acute myeloid
leukemia
understanding the molecular immunologic
profiling of cytotoxic t cell responses
in patients receiving engineered dc
vaccine
and finally find what geomics platform
can offer us with fully validated
antibodies
to meet the spatial profiling needs in
every laboratory
our first speaker is peter nelson
professor of medicine at the university
of washington
who will present the spatial landscape
of the immune microenvironment in
metastatic prostate cancer
hi my name is uh pete nelson uh from the
fred hutchinson cancer research center
in seattle and i'm going to be speaking
about uh some work that we've done
focusing on understanding the spatial
landscapes
of metastatic prostate cancer with a
particular focus on the
immune micro environment and this
analysis was really made
possible by using the digital spatial
profiling technology so i represent
a large research group as shown on this
slide with
collaborators at the university of
washington at
fred hutch as well as uh at dennis
string
these are my conflicts none of which
really have direct bearing
on the discussion that i'll provide here
so this is an outline of what i'll focus
on
first just to lay the landscape out
of why we're focusing on advanced
prostate cancer
i'll describe some major research
directions
uh the study design for the
aspects of digital spatial profiling and
then get into
two areas of results first focusing on
the
heterogeneity that we observe in
metastatic prostate cancer
and then a dive into immune responses
within these metastases and then i'll
end up with a few
conclusions and future directions for
next steps
so prostate cancer in 2020
is a highly lethal disease with more
than 30 000 deaths a year
these are essentially all attributed to
metastatic prostate cancer
you can see on this slide bone is a very
dominant
site as shown by this nuclear medicine
bone scan
essentially when you see metastatic
prostate cancer such as this
it is currently incurable
so how can we approach mortality
we think about this in four ways one
understanding the drivers of the
metastatic process and
survival in advanced disease we'd like
to apply specific therapies the whole
concept of precision medicine
um anticipating and understanding
resistance mechanisms and then
co-targeting these
anticipated resistance mechanisms so
we've deployed many therapeutics and
advanced prostate cancer
including immune-based therapies which
i'll
get back to overall immune based
therapies
the typical checkpoint blockade
inhibitors have not worked well
in prostate cancer with the exception of
a very rare subtype
of hypermutated disease due to mispatch
repair
we now recognize that advanced prostate
cancer has numerous
subtypes these can be defined
genomically so this is a study
from the stand up to cancer dream team
profiling metastatic prostate cancer
what you can glean from this is that
there are many
recurrent genomic events so
each row here is a different genomic
event
each column is a different tumor or
metastatic site
androgen receptor right at the top is
the most frequently altered
genomic event in advanced prostate
cancer and you can see
that there are many others that are
either frequent
or infrequent the panel on the right
compares these genomic alterations in
localized prostate cancer that's the
y-axis versus the alterations in
metastatic prostate cancer
on the x-axis you can see that certain
events are clearly enriched
in metastatic disease
we now recognize after we apply
therapeutic pressure
most of this focuses on targeting the
androgen receptor
that we're not seeing resistance
mechanisms that are phenotypically
defined often by the development of
transdifferentiation to phenotypes such
as neuroendocrine prostate cancer
a stem cell phenotype mesenchymal basal
cell
etc so in addition to the underlying
genomic events
we now see phenotypic events some of
which are clearly
related to an underlying genomic event
but others
we still don't understand the process so
this is some recent work
looking at the phenotypes based on gene
expression
this becomes relevant as we get into the
digital spatial profiling that i'll talk
about in a moment
what you can see here is that we can
categorize
metastatic prostate cancer based on
androgen receptor activity and
neuroendocrine activity
into at least in this case five
phenotypes based on gene expression so
we have androgen receptor high
neuroendocrine low those are the green
bars
androgen receptor high neuroendocrine
high or amphicrine tumors in red
androgen receptor low neuroendocrine low
in purple endogenous receptor low
neuroendocrine negative
in blue and then the androgen receptor
negative neuroendocrine positive
in yellow so our major research and
clinical questions
relevant to this presentation one is
what's the extent of
inter and intra
tumor heterogeneity with respect to
these phenotypes and metastatic prostate
cancer
and then second why is prostate cancer
essentially refractory to current immune
based therapies such as
immune checkpoint blockade so the first
could this heterogeneity impact therapy
resistance
and then the second are there other
immune targets
present in these metastatic tumors where
we may
redirect future therapies and studies
so our study design we really wanted to
understand
inter and intra tumor heterogeneity
using digital spatial profiling
and then also determine if there were
particular immune features of metastatic
prostate cancer that we could also
identify so our study design is as
follows we
used tumors that we acquire from a rapid
autopsy
program developed by colin morrissey at
the university of washington
in this case we looked at 28 patients
we looked at two metastases from each
patient
these were arrayed on tissue microarrays
where we
obtained three cores from each of these
tumors
so we in total have 178 samples
for this study initially we took one
roi or region of interest from
each of these arrayed tma cores
overall because prostate cancer
metastasizes to different
sites we were able to sample 16
different
tissue sites such as bone lung liver
and lymph node we used the
geomics dsp workflow
which i believe other presenters have
described so i'm not going to get into a
lot of detail here
uh basically the approach uses
uh for protein detection an antibody
that's tagged with an oligonucleotide
barcode
or for gene transcript expression
and oligo targeting a particular
messenger rna
or cdna where you have that also
bar-coded
you then choose regions of interest
microscopically
and use uv light to cleave the barcode
which is then
aspirated and dispensed into microtiter
plates and then you can either sequence
it
through next-gen sequencing or to
encounter assays
in this case from each tma we took three
sections the first for
h e and immunohistochemistry
the second for digital spatial profiling
using
rna this sampled about 2100 genes
with multiple probes per transcript
so about 18 000 probes and then for
protein
we looked at 60 antibodies
that were also tagged
okay so the results of this study first
inter and intra
head tumor heterogeneity across these
metastases
so the first question we had is does
digital spatial profiling
classify the prostate cancer phenotypes
that we had previously
identified using based
bulk tumor analysis so this slides a
little bit complicated but
the color coding is as follows at the
very top
we're looking at the different sites for
metastases for example
in red that would be a bone metastasis
then we have a series
of gene expression signatures
indicating a pathway or a program
activity
so we have androgen receptor
neuroendocrine activity ccp which is a
cell cycle progression score a surrogate
for proliferation
and then the fourth is for fgf and map
kinase signaling
which we've been interested in as a
therapeutic target
then the line below that shows the class
determined by bulk rna-seq and then
below that
is the class that we assigned by digital
spatial profiling
using the nanostring technology
so you can see that first of all
dsp based classification
clearly separates these tumors into the
different phenotypic categories that we
previously have determined by rna-seq
you can see
that shown on the upper right pca
plot below that we've compared
the androgen receptor signature of
activity
and the cell cycle progression ccp score
comparing the dsp based uh
result with and that's on the x-axis
with the rna-seq based result
for that same tumor on the y-axis you
can see
very high uh concordance here
so this really confirmed our
impression of the accuracy of dsp-based
classification of these tumor samples
that was
at least equivalent to the rna-seq based
bulk sequencing
importantly we were also able to
sample bone so this has been
traditionally a very difficult
tissue site to work with because for
example cutting sections or processing
this
often requires um pretty
severe decalcification processing steps
so these bone samples did go through our
traditional decal
procedure overall the signal
intensity or the the signal for each
transcript was generally
lower in the bone sample compared to the
soft tissue
however it was readily sufficient to
classify
each tumor based on its phenotype and
also
we were able to find bone specific
features if you look at the far
right panel this is a soft tissue
metastases
and a bone metastasis from the same
patient
comparing the two and we can see that
there are certain bone derived
factors particularly found in that bone
sample so this was a is an attribute
for this approach i would also say that
i didn't mention it earlier but all of
the
dsp-based gene expression studies
were done on formal and fixed samples
dating back up to 10 years
the rna-seq was done on
uh frozen uh samples
so um again using the formalin fixed is
a
is also a major asset in this type of uh
assay and allowing you to use
retrospective samples
that may not have been collected in a
frozen state
so the next question was what's the
extent of intra-individual
or inter-tumor so in this case what
we're doing is we're looking at
the multiple tumors from each individual
so we've shown
the patients at the top as i mentioned
each patient had two tumors at least
sampled here and so you can see the
particular site
of bone liver lymph node lung or other
soft tissue
and then those gene expression programs
that i described earlier around androgen
receptor neuroendocrine etc
and then the classification based on dsp
so you can see that most of these tumors
within a patient did have the same
phenotype determined by dsp however
there were some tumors here that were
clearly distinctly
different so you can see for example
patient 12
0 1 1 the second patient over from the
left
had one tumor classified as amphicrine
or ar-positive neuroendocrine positive
and another tumor classified as
ar-positive neuroendocrine negative
so generally concordance
across metastases within a patient but
clearly
some outliers or some divergence in that
and here's an example of one such case
15069 so here are two different
metastases
you can see that their ar signaling or
androgen receptor signaling
is highly concordant within these two
different metastatic sites
but the neuroendocrine signaling is
shown on the bottom panel
is clearly divergent so these tumors
classified
phenotypically distinctly
so the next question was what's the
extent of
intra tumor heterogeneity so this is
where the spatial profiling
can really shine where the bulk rna-seq
failed to provide this level of
discrimination so
now what we've done here is taken all of
the tumors
and i'm showing you the individual
regions of
interest so i mentioned each for each
tumor
we sample three different rois
from within each metastatic site
so uh that's what is shown here so for
each patient
we're looking at six different rois
three
from each of those tumors so we're
starting to
identify here that there is some degree
of intra tumor heterogeneity with expect
with respect to gene expression here
here i'm showing you one example patient
17017
where if you look at the far right at
the top
one of the rois is distinctly different
in terms of its expression compared to
the remainder
of the roi so we were starting to get
some idea
that there may be some intra-tumor
heterogeneity here so by bulk
rna-seq again if we look across
the two tumors from each patient there
was an 82 percent
intra individual concordance that is
those two tumors from each patient
had the same phenotype called
and those were boxed however if we look
at the individual rois from those tumors
that intra-individual concordance drops
substantially to 64 percent
so that 10 tumors here were discordant
when you started to
go and look at the individual regions
within those tumors so i'll highlight
one
particular patient here in red
15096 so in this case we had
an impression that there may be
heterogeneity
within this particular metastases
so what i'm showing here is the
simply h and e section the full face
section
of this metastasis where you can
clearly see tumor regions within this
particular metastatic site by
immune histo or immunofluorescence
really for pan cytokeratin
cd3 and dna you can see that there
appears to be some
diversity within this metastases
so we took a deep dive and sampled
approximately 18 regions of interest
across this different tumor and what i'm
showing you
on the bottom are several of those rois
pretty much marching across the face of
this tumor
roi7 being right in the middle of that
pan ck positive green region
then you start losing the pancetta
keratin as you go across
and then the digital spatial profiling
uh
on the right shows that um at the
roi within that cytokeratin positive
region
you have high uh androgen receptor
activity
as read out by ar regulated genes such
as
tarp and tmprs2 and then as you go
across
the face of this tumor into the more
distant regions you
lose androgen receptor signaling and you
actually gain
neuroendocrine gene expression activity
and you also
gain kinase signaling and fgf
expression as you can see by the
middle and lower panel and we know
clinically that we need to treat these
tumors distinctly differently than an
androgen receptor active tumor
so the bulk rna-seq from this tumor
suggests that there was an amphicrine
tumor that they were ar
high plus neuroendocrine high but once
you
dig into the heterogeneity within it you
see that there was
actually not amphicrine per se there
were regions that were
ar positive neuroendocrine negative and
other regions that were
a are negative neuroendocrine positive
so another question that we wanted to
address
was to actually look at splice variants
uh it turns out the androgen receptor
has a number of splice variants that
promote resistance to
typical androgen receptor directed
therapy
so within the transcript based
digital spatial profiling we designed a
series of probes
that could distinguish the different
androgen receptor splice variants so
this slide
is simply showing you that there are
many different splice variants
do for example to the inclusion of
cryptic exons
i'll show you that in more detail in a
moment and a new england journal paper
showing that one of these splice
variants arv7
again promoted resistance to androids
and receptor targeting
so here's the structure of the androgen
receptor it's comprised of eight
canonical exons and it turns out with
the splice variant in this case
arv7 there's a cryptic exon
cryptic exon 3 that ends up being
spliced
in and you lose expression
of the more distant exons
here so what we did is design
probes used for dsp
that would capture cryptic exon 3
and we can compare that with a ratio of
exon 4 to derive whether or not a tumor
does or doesn't express
arv7 so here's the analysis
if we look across all of the tumors
across these metastases
and the individual rois if you look down
at the second line from the bottom
this is the arv 7 level assessed by
rna-seq
just bulk rna-seq from the tumors
so you get an idea that most of these
tumors
either express arv7 or they don't
however by digital spatial profiling you
see
much more heterogeneity within
the tumor with respect to arv7
expression so ongoing work is designed
to determine
does this degree of heterogeneity
contribute
to resistance to ar targeted therapy
that may not be apparent from sequencing
bulk tumor
this shows you the regions of interest
for example for this particular
case that i'm showing 1205 and 12011
and the diversity of arv7 by digital
spatial profiling
which wasn't apparent by bulk rna-seq
okay so the last section here focuses on
immune response in prostate cancer
metastases
what we started off by noting
is that if we look at markers that
denote
particular immune cells so t cells b
cells and even subtypes of these is that
the vast majority of these metastases
really lack any substantial immune cell
infiltrates now the caveat here is that
this analysis is entirely focused on
intra-tumoral regions of interest
we are not in this case looking at the
peritumoral region
or region in the stroma so again with no
notable exceptions there were a few very
few
tumors with any substantial intra-tumor
inflammatory
infiltrates and interestingly we also
saw that
there was high consistency with any
particular immune cell marker across the
multiple
rois from the tumors
from the same patient regardless
of the metastatic site so for example
if you had a metastases in lymph node
versus bone
you basically saw the same immune cell
repertoire so again with some notable
exceptions these were
pretty devoid of cells the the two
highlights that i have here
uh one shows a t cell response in all of
the rois across metastases
and then the other orange highlighted
tumor shows
um multiple different cell types
immune cell types within the two
metastases from that patient that are
distinctly different than the rest
of the patient metastases so
the other notable thing is that if we
order these
now these tumors not by patient but by
phenotype so in green or the ar
active neuroendocrine low etc on the
left
and on the far right we span all the way
through to the
double negative cases ar negative or
endocrine negative
so you can see that there are some
features that are so
immune cell features that associate with
phenotype
generally the macrophages
are present in the androgen receptor
negative or low
subtype that i've circled here in orange
we also looked at cytokine programs and
immune markers
and found that these are also conserved
across multiple metastases from a given
patient
i won't go into all the individuals ones
here you can
view them on your own on these slides
if we then order these by phenotype
rather than patient
we can also see that cytokine programs
and immune markers
associate with the phenotype of the
prostate cancer
beyond simply the
different patient sites
so what's the composition of these so
of interest the ar negative near
endocrine tumors
and they are negative neuroendocrine
positive tumors are the ones
with some intratumoral immune
infiltrates
but the garden variety prostate cancer
those that are androgen receptor
positive neuroendocrine negative
are immune cold here we can see that in
these
ar negative neuroendocrine negative
tumors there's high
cd8 b and prf1 which are associated with
study toxic
t cells also tap one which is involved
in
antigen processing possibly associated
with attraction of t
cells as a hypothesis here and then
in the stromal region this is an example
where we did look at the stroma
we can see that there are cd68
positive monocyte or macrophages is the
predominant immune cell type in the
tumor microenvironment for these
metastases
we also see high levels of perituberal
cd163 positive cells
which is a marker of protumorogenic
macrophages
so the dsp technology also allows you to
profile
protein as i mentioned so we looked at
in this case i'm showing you 57 of the
60 antibodies that were profiled
we use the same tissue microarrays that
we use for the
dsp of transcripts so it provides
another another level of confidence
number one of the transcript
measurements and also
can determine other biology that you may
miss
simply by transcript levels so
importantly we were able to show that if
we compare the dsp-based
transcript measurements with the
dsp-based
protein measurements there was very high
degree of concordance
i'm just showing you androgen receptor
and uh a proliferation marker
uh and then synaptin which is a mark of
neuroendocrine
tumor so um these were again highly
concordant for
those expected uh they are
active associated neuroendocrine
associated markers
so we also showed that um
androgen receptor measurement by protein
did associate with those tumors that we
classified
as ar high also the neuroendocrine
marker
cd56 or ncam is high
in the neuroendocrine tumors as is
synaptophizin so those are the tumors on
the far right
kind of shown in the yellow
circles so
i mentioned earlier in the discussion
that prostate cancer
is highly resistant to immune-based
therapy
it turns out by this analysis very few
tumors expressed
any sort of signal for pdl-1
or pd-1 ctla-4
has also been evaluated in prostate
cancer as well as melanoma
we found very low levels of ctla-4
checkpoint
in these metastatic sites very
interestingly
and unexpectedly we found very high
expression
of b7h3 another
immune checkpoint molecule here we're
comparing
on the far right the transcript based
and the protein-based
measurements of each of these checkpoint
molecules
confirming very low expression of ctla4
pd1 and pdl1
and very high expression of b7h3
b7h3 or otherwise known as td-276
does have some role in inhibiting t-cell
function
it has a variety of other involvement in
in the immune system as well as
promotion of tumor growth
it's expressed on a variety of tumor
types
this cartoon on the left is a very nice
review
describing p7h3
we found b7h3 was very highly expressed
on the ar active ar high tumors
but much less so on the neuroendocrine
and arnold tumors
and this coincided with the expression
of another immune checkpoint
tim3 so this is a
deep dive into one of the tumors
where we looked at multiple regions of
interest
the vast majority of these rois
expressed very high
and tgf beta however there were a few
regions
that had lower level of expression so
ongoing work is designed to try to
understand
this heterogeneity and determine if it
if cd 276 or b7h3 may be
a reasonable target specifically in
prostate
cancer so i'll conclude here
just to recap i tried to
show you that castration resistant
metastatic prostate cancer comprises
many subtypes
some are defined by genomic alterations
some
by phenotype the dsp based profiling
spatial profiling really demonstrated
very high correlation
with rna-seq based methods to define
prostate cancer subtypes
we found profound intra-tumoral
heterogeneity
that rna-seq had missed in several
tumors
the use of formal and fixed paraffin and
vet embedded materials
that had been arrayed on tissue
microarrays was a major advantage for
rapid throughput
and then we did also show that dsp
based protein quantitation correlated
with traditional
immunohistic immunohistochemistry and
allows you also to multiplex we also
showed that
these subtypes can coexist within
and across metastatic tumors from the
same patient
and notably very few inflammatory cells
within these tumors of any type the most
predominant being macrophages
um the vast majority had no cd8 or cd4
t cells we also found very limited
expression
of immune checkpoint molecules where fda
approved therapies
have been used which may explain the
lack of treatment efficacy and prostate
cancer
and nominate a new immune checkpoint
target b7h3
that associates with the most common
phenotype of advanced prostate cancer
that expresses
androgen receptor activity so the future
directions center on determining
if the heterogeneity and phenotype as
has been shown for
genotype associates treatment outcomes
we also want to test therapeutic
strategies that co-target
coexisting phenotypes and defining this
may best be done by spatial tumor
analysis
um we also suggest that b7h3 may be a
reasonable target
for immune checkpoint blockade and
trials
in advanced prostate cancer and then
finally
we'd like to further determine
associations between the phenotypes
and the tissue microenvironment
components
by also evaluating the peritumoral and
stromal regions using spatial profiling
so we have many funding sources that
supported this work that i've shown here
including the
nci prostate cancer foundation
department of defense as well as support
from
nanastring and then many collaborators
first and foremost
acknowledging the patients and families
that participated in the rapid autopsy
program number of investigators at fred
hutch the university of washington
and at nana string so i'll stop there
and be happy to
answer questions thank you
are there known drivers of tumor
plasticity and phenotyping
so currently we don't know the specific
drivers of tumor plasticity and
heterogeneity but there are clear
associations for example
the ability for a prostate cancer to
transdifferentiate
that is move from one phenotype to
another
plasticity underlying that is
retinol is loss of two tumor suppressors
retinoblastoma
rb1 and p53 and p10 loss probably
plays a role as well these are more
permissive
to allow for plasticity in the context
of repressing
androgen receptor signaling so a lot of
work in the field is trying to
understand this
more stem-like state that's conferred by
loss of p53 and rb that mirrors
what we see in small cell lung cancer as
well so
i think it's a very exciting and
important area of work to see if
we could prevent this
transdifferentiation
what were the microenvironment features
that contribute to therapy resistance
and could they be assessed by dsp
so there are a number of micro
environment features
that we think may contribute to
treatment resistance for example we know
that
most of the therapeutics that we use to
treat
both localized and advanced cancers are
not exclusive
for damaging if you will the tumor cell
they also have effects on the
microenvironment
a number of studies have shown that
damage responses in the microenvironment
usually due to genotoxic stress dna
damaging agents like radiation platinum
chemotherapy and others
can induce a secretory program from that
micro environment
these include went signaling factors
much regulated by nf kappa b it also
influences the immune cell in the immune
environment which
in some cases could promote therapy
resistance and tumor growth
so these microenvironment features
are ideally suited to be assayed
by digital spatial profiling
can you compare and contrast the dsp
analysis of transcripts
versus protein
right so comparing assay
of transcripts and protein by dsp
one of the the major advantages of dsp
is
essentially within the same tissue
sample or the same
tumor sample you can acquire both
protein information
and transcript information so
the transcripts currently
are allowing for many more genes to be
acid
you can certainly multiplex proteins in
the data that i
showed we're looking at about 60
proteins
one of the challenges that each antibody
has to be
tagged specifically and worked up to
show that it's going to perform exactly
the same way
as a non-tagged antibody so some of the
preservatives need to be accounted for
in terms of the antibody
but clearly protein levels don't always
equate to transcript levels
and they're certainly things that we're
missing at the transcript level that may
be
altered at the protein level some say
the major difference currently is being
able to sample many many more genes
by the transcript based assays
potentially the entire transcriptome
whereas proteins at this point require a
good antibody
but using both assays simultaneously
certainly gives you
both higher confidence in any individual
measurement
and also provides some complementary
information where transcripts for
example may not equate
to expression of a particular protein
either in the tumor or the micro
environment
are there issues with particular samples
for example the age
or an ffpe tissue block
so there clearly are issues with
particular samples
we were fortunate to be able to use this
rapid autopsy program for our analysis
and we clearly excluded certain samples
that
for example had severe necrosis within
them
but we did show that dating back about
10 years
these samples that were formal and fixed
and archived
still had a very suitable nucleic acid
and protein for the dsp-based
analysis and that's something that we
wouldn't have been able to
evaluate at the like using a technology
such as rna-seq
we don't know if even older ffpe
tissue blocks would be suitable they
very well may be but
we don't know at this point in time but
at least in our case
dating back eight to ten years they were
perfectly
suitable for dsp bone is still a
challenge no doubt
um the samples that we looked at overall
had lower signal
uh for the transcript profiles likely
due
to the processing that needed to be done
for decalcification
but there are some methods where you
don't need to
use as harsh of conditions for decal
and so i would anticipate that those
samples would
be a better quality even than the ones
that we use so
i certainly wouldn't rule out bone as a
as a routine analyte
but they should be considered carefully
are there spatial aspects to immune
cells in prostate metastasis that may
influence tumor behaviors
or treatment responses
right so um we don't really know at this
point
whether there is a spatial influence
for immune cells in the metastases
that's a very important very interesting
question
i think that has been assessed in
other tumor types where you actually do
see
robust immune responses for example two
to immune checkpoint blockade for
example in melanoma bladder cancer and
some lung cancers
the problem is in prostate cancer we
have yet to see
consistent robust responses with the
exceptions of those
tumors that have high mutation burdens
due to mismatch repair deficiencies so
i think once we start to develop
cohorts of patients that we do see
responses to
with ideally uh a new
immune checkpoint uh blockade strategy
or
uh car t cell-based methods that we will
be able to
assess the role of or the response of
the spatial
contribution to treatments
so that's an active area of work and as
i mentioned
in my talk we haven't yet
done a rigorous analysis of the
peritumoral
composition which could be related to
prostate cancer phenotype or the
subtypes and potentially to treatment
responses so that's
ongoing work that we hope to complete
the next six to 12 months
so i appreciate your attention
what i tried to demonstrate here and
show
to the digital spatial profiling is that
advanced or metastatic prostate cancer
clearly has different phenotypes with
spatial
influences that may be important in
understanding
disease progression in response to
therapy
and the striking lack of immune cells
within these
metastases so this really opens up
the opportunity for future work in
enhancing immune responses
and also taking into account tumor
heterogeneity as we consider different
combinations of therapies for advanced
cancers
so i want to thank all of the my
colleagues
the people that actually did the work
related to these studies at fred hutch
the university of washington and nana
string
and again thanks for your attention